i am someone who
prides myself a lot on my time
management and i think that i balance a
lot of things in my life really well the
sort of downside to that is that i'm
constantly working you know i'm
constantly like moving from one thing to
the next and it's really difficult to
stay in the moment you know if we were
doing this pre-therapy i'd be thinking
about okay as soon as i leave this this
podcast i'm going to go home i'm going
to have a 10-minute coffee break then
i'm going to sit down for half an hour
and i'm going to work on my emails and
then i'm going to have a two-hour study
session with kenji and georgina my
parents are going to come we're going to
go for dinner i wouldn't be thinking
about us in this moment right now i
would always be thinking about what's
next what sex what's next and i used to
keep track of every single thing i did
in my life i was just very hyper focused
on time through therapy i've realized
that i can still complete everything i
want to do in my life without
necessarily sort of working on the to-do
list up until i go to sleep at midnight
or you know constantly squeezing in
little bits of work on the bus on the
train when i'm walking things like that
i've taken like a much more relaxed
attitude towards life hey friends
welcome back to deep dive my name is ali
and in each episode of the podcast i
chat to authors entrepreneurs creators
and other inspiring people about how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools that can help along
our shared journey of living happier
healthier more productive lives and this
episode is a discussion with nasir
harmer who is a final year medical
student at king's college london here in
the uk best known for his youtube
channel called karma medic where he
talks about productivity about education
about lifestyle and teaches generally
students and young people how to be more
productive with that time nasa has been
doing this for the past few years now
and he's a master following of over one
million people which is pretty sick and
so in this conversation we talk about
how he first started this youtube thing
what was it that inspired him to start
this youtube channel and get it to a
ridiculously successful point while
being a full-time medical student and
then the conversation takes a bit of a
turn and we talk a lot about what it
means to live a meaningful life and some
of the lessons that nasa has learned
from going to therapy for example and
some of the ways that his thoughts and
insights around productivity around what
it means to work hard and be effective
have changed over time langston's
youtube channel and all his other stuff
will be in the show notes and in the
video description and i hope you enjoy
this conversation between me and karma
medic we're sitting here today you are
fast approaching a million subscribers
you're a final year medical student at
king's college london and you've just
gotten uh news that you're going to be
working in north london so
congratulations on that front thank you
very much how how did we end up here
what's what's the story of comma medic
what's the story of karma medic um we
need to go pretty far back let's go back
i love going back um okay so
how this kind of all started is that um
when i graduated high school uh in
greece i wanted to go to medical school
and i applied to
um the four most prestigious
universities that me and my father could
come up with because my dad said i'm
only paying international fees for you
to study abroad if you get accepted into
one of the top top top unis and i said
you know what fair enough i guess that
makes sense
so we did i applied to them and i didn't
end up getting accepted anywhere so i
did my plan b of going to study in
canada because that's where i was born
so i hold the canadian citizenship
and i did my undergraduate degree there
after my undergraduate degree i still
wanted to apply to medical school it was
always the goal from from the time i was
in high school and um i eventually
applied to both canada and the uk i got
accepted in the uk and that's where i
went
now when i got accepted in the uk i felt
like it had been such a long journey of
me trying to get accepted into medical
school lots of like obstacles ups and
downs you know the whole shebang that a
lot of people go through as well um and
i kind of told myself that i want to
help a couple other people get accepted
to medical school a handful of people um
and
when i and i wasn't really sure how to
go about that i started like a reddit
forum and uh sorry i put out post on
reddit um i went on the student room
forum and i put out a post there saying
hey i just got accepted if you have any
questions blah blah got like zero
attraction zero comments whatever and i
was like okay well this isn't helping me
achieve my goal so i started the youtube
channel and uh that's kind of how it got
started so how old were you when you
started the youtube channel
um i was in my second year of medical
school so that would have made me 23 i
think okay so you're in your second year
and were you doing undergrad medicine or
grad medicine so undergraduate medicine
okay i had made the conscious decision
to apply to undergraduate because the
graduate medicine was even more
competitive for international
graduates um and so yeah i went for that
i see okay so you did four years of a
canadian college
um like canadian university canadian
university and then and now you're doing
a second
undergraduate degree yes because the aim
was always medical school from day one
exactly yeah interesting um what was
what was the experience of canadian
university like compared to medical
school because obviously i've only
experienced medical school so i yeah i
always think like ooh canada looks cool
america looks cool you get to do all
these different subjects rather than
just one thing like yeah yeah what was
that like
there's there's a lot of differences
between the two like studying systems
and a lot of pros and cons on either
side i think thinking back to my time in
canada the one thing that really stands
out for me is just how difficult it was
i think um
the the difficult part about being in
the canadian or the american system is
that you have this gpa system and so
your final grade that you graduate
university with is sort of a compilation
of every single exam essay quiz
assignment that you take in every course
in every year and so there's this
constant really intense pressure to
perform well throughout the four years
and so the standard degree length is
four years there as opposed to like
three years here and so i guess in
comparison to the uk where you have
these big exams at the end of the year
that you need to study really hard for
and those are what count towards your
degree and a lot of times the first year
and second year don't really count as
much
but i'm happy you brought up the fact
that you know you study loads of
different subjects not just
the thing that you applied for so for
example i wanted to do medicine so i did
life sciences which is like this broad
thing and then you choose
sort of underneath that your majors or
your minors and so i did two majors in a
minor
and you get to do all kinds of courses
not only in science but also like i did
shakespeare for a whole year i did uh
computer science i did physics maths
chemistry
and what else ancient egyptian like you
know you can take a whole wide variety
of courses which i think is fantastic
makes a for a really interesting
university experience okay and and so i
guess you had to maintain a pretty
reasonable gpa as you were going through
canadian university to then even start a
chance of getting into medical school
yeah
and um
and even with the pretty decent gpa that
i maintained it was nowhere near close
enough to the competitive gpas uh for
canadian medical schools oh wow
yeah and i'll i'll die on this hill that
i put every last blood sweat and tear
into maintaining my grades over the four
years of my canadian university and i'm
so happy with the grade that i finished
with um but it's just not even close to
the competitiveness that you need um so
yeah it's really really tough out there
what are those what are the what are the
people with the 4.0 gps doing like
friends who got like
amazing grades like what was their
experience like yeah i had some friends
who did really really well um and i
think it's you know i'm a combination of
them you know probably just being
smarter than me at the end of the day um
maybe working a bit harder and um
maybe less of a social life that kind of
stuff and you have to be really smart
about what courses you take because you
want to take the easier courses that
will give you the better gpa um which i
didn't know too much about back then uh
yeah it strikes me that there is kind of
a game to it and some people are very
good at playing the game yeah absolutely
and like if i
if i look at like so i've i've got a
friend my old housemate who i used to
live with who consistently ranked in the
top three in the year group
and like
the the amount he worked was not
radically different to the amount i
worked and yet he just did so much
better than i ever did yeah like what is
going on there is it natural
intelligence or is it just something
about the way that he's working or
studying or whatever
that is
resulting in a different a different
outcome um
like now that you've sort of done this
whole productivity study type stuff
stuff on youtube have you come across
any things that you sort of wish you'd
known back in the day study techniques
productivity hacks stuff that
would have made life a bit easier when
you were going through like all these
years of like 10 years of university i
think honestly one of the biggest things
that i needed to know earlier was
studying smart not just studying for
long periods of time especially when i
was in high school i kind of had the
impression and understanding that the
more hours you spent sitting down at
your desk the better your exam score was
going to be and i do think there is a
strong correlation there
but there's a balance and you or i've
found that it's better to focus you know
on the high-yield material don't spend
so much time going into the weeds you
use practice paper questions group
studying whatever there's all kinds of
things that i just didn't know i was
just i thought the best way to study was
to take notes and sit at your desk lock
yourself in your room for hours and
hours on end which is a huge mistake um
there's much better ways to do it for
sure yeah
okay yeah and we'll put links to our
respective videos on the on the topic
down below if people if you want to
check them out
uh why were you so into medicine that
you would go through all these hoops to
get into med school like you would have
made that decision when you were like 16
or something so yeah what's what's going
on there
absolutely um i always say that when i
made the decision to apply for medical
school i said that i want to be a doctor
and i put these air quotes around
because i quite honestly had no idea
what being a doctor was the only thing i
knew about being a doctor is what i saw
in the movies right when i made that
decision
[Music]
and so it was more the work experiences
that i did over the coming years and
speaking to people who are in research
labs in academia speaking to people who
are working in the hospital going and
spending some time in the hospital
that i actually kind of understood what
does the day-to-day of a doctor look
like and that's kind of what reinforced
the idea that i want to be a doctor and
now became i actually want to be a
doctor
um
yeah it was more like the real life
experiences that i had that pushed me
towards it let's say you're speaking to
someone who doesn't really know what to
do with their career and they don't
necessarily want to do medicine
what would you kind of advise them like
how should they how should they go about
this i think like work experience is by
far the best
way if you don't do it you're not gonna
know i understand you know getting work
experience is pretty hard for a lot of
people especially in different kinds of
careers and and whatnot but the only way
to really know what it's gonna be like
is work experience i think the second
best thing to that honestly is watching
people on youtube talk about their job
talk about their career it's funny but
like um whenever i need to know anything
the first thing i do is search on
youtube and i look for someone who's
gone through that experience and i just
watch them and that's like the most real
way of understanding it i think reading
a blog or i don't know some company talk
about what their career is like isn't
really the best way of getting that
information across we're going to take a
very quick break to introduce our
sponsor for this episode who is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last few years and they're a
fantastic interactive platform with
online courses in maths science and
computer science my personal favorites
are the computer science courses i think
are absolutely fantastic and when i was
initially applying to med school i was
actually torn between applying to
medicine and applying to computer
science and i ended up going with
medicine in the end which i really don't
regret but there's a big part of me that
really wanted to continue learning the
stuff around computer science continuing
to understand how coding works and the
courses on brilliant have given me that
foundation in computer science which i
didn't have before the courses are
really fun engaging and interactive and
the way they teach you stuff is based on
very first principles thinking like
they'll teach you a concept and then
they'll take you through interactive
exercises to actually help solidify your
understanding of that concept and it's
pretty cool because they're always
updating the library with new courses
for example there's one they've just
released called maths which is kind of
like a visual exploration of the maths
that we use in everyday life like for
example fractions and percentages and
putting them in a context that makes it
very understandable and certainly very
different to the kind of boring way that
i was taught maths when i was in school
the courses and lessons are particularly
good if you have a busy life with lots
of stuff going on because they really
teach you the stuff in bite-sized chunks
so you can always return to a course at
a later date if you don't have time to
do it in one sitting if any of that
stands up your straight then do head
over to brilliant.org forward slash deep
dive and the first 200 people to hit
that link which is also going to be in
the video description and in the show
notes we'll get 20 of the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
yeah there's a lot of stuff on youtube
these are like day in the life of almost
any career that you could imagine and so
it's it's relatively easy to get some
level of information obviously if
someone's like a lawyer or a management
consultant or even a doctor there is a
degree to which they are not going to
give you the true honest
vibe of exactly what's going on um
yeah so i guess i i want to come back to
the medicine thing in a moment but so in
your second year you decided you want to
start a youtube channel yeah um
most people i know who started youtube
channels have not started it with the
altruistic intention of helping people
get into uni and there is always an
element of like status money prestige
etc
etc
to what extent did the kind of more
selfish motives for being a youtuber
kind of affect your decision in the past
and i guess now as well yeah um i
remember we talked about this like the
last time i saw you in cambridge and
after i gave you my answer you were like
i don't believe you there there must be
something selfish there um so
so the truth is i think
over time with the youtube channel the
selfish reasons have grown larger and
larger when it first started it
genuinely was an altruistic thing i
remember um when i got the email that i
was accepted to medical school i went on
to this like huge grass field outside
the library where i was and i called my
mom and like she started crying i
started crying and i said to her on the
phone i said i'm gonna help a handful of
other students have the same feeling
that i have
and that really was the motivating
driver behind me starting the youtube
channel yeah um as time has gone on and
sort of the very intense passion and
spark and fire inside me that was
creating a video every single week
um has sort of well i wouldn't say it
died down but it's certainly not as
strong as it used to be um the more
selfish reasons sort of kick in and you
know i feel like i already have this big
platform let me keep growing it this can
open doors for me in the future etc etc
um but it definitely started as a fully
altruistic thing ah interesting and so
what were your feelings in those early
days when you put out a video and no one
watches it like that sort of experience
that we've all we've all been through
yeah
it was definitely tough
and i remember the first time i had a
subscriber i was visiting alexia in
bristol and i was like jumping up and
down the first person who subscribed to
my channel um
those early days i think
the the hardest thing was that as you
mentioned you know no one watches the
video and no one comments
and so
right at the beginning how i was sort of
spreading the word about these videos
was i was going on the student room
forum
and i was going to the ucat and bmat
sections of that page and whenever
people would ask questions i would
answer them and then say hey if you want
some more help dm me they would dm me
and i'd be like i'd respond to their
question again and then send a link to
the youtube channel because if you sent
the link on the forum you would get
banned yep and i got banned several
times for doing that so so i had to find
this workaround with the dm
um
and so that's kind of how i started
getting my first few viewers and
followers and
even the one two three people who were
watching at the time found the videos
really helpful and found them really
valuable the feedback was so
overwhelmingly positive that you know it
gave me this real sense of i'm doing
something meaningful here and that made
it easier to sort of continue pushing
videos out every single week you know
staying up late like sacrificing sleep
and whatever
um
i think it's because i got that positive
feedback really early on
ah okay so you went out there and
hustled to get people to actually watch
your videos i hustled hard yeah yeah for
sure i think a lot of people wouldn't do
that they would put the video up hit
publish hope for the best and then
complain three videos later and no one's
watching their videos no i i put in a
lot of work for sure i was answering
like comments and dms and whatever for a
long time yeah yeah and it was pure
altruism at that point
like i said i had this goal of helping i
don't remember what the number was now i
think somewhere between like 10 and 50
people get accepted to medical school um
and so i was kind of just continuing to
go until i had talked to 10 different
people 50 different people whatever
did you ever have to battle with like
perfectionism of like this video sucks
and i wanted to be better and therefore
i'm not going to upload it anything any
thoughts like that um
yeah
uh i i think that definitely i i
characterize myself i think of myself as
a perfectionist type person but i draw a
really strict line in the sand where
perfectionism should not be so much to
the point that it stops me from doing
the thing that i actually want to do
and so when i would edit my videos and
when i would film them you know i would
work really hard to try and get things
as best as they could
but at the end of the day i would have
to upload it no matter what even if it
wasn't my best piece of work because i
recognized how much value there was in
just learning one new thing every single
time i knew that i wasn't going to be
making good videos overnight and i knew
that the first ones were going to be bad
and it's just part of the process i
didn't i didn't really care too much i
just wanted to
learn if that makes sense
yeah this i mean i that's all
all great in in theory and i think
anyone who starts on youtube or putting
themselves out there and writing or in
anything
knows intellectually that
this is going to be crap but then
there's a difference between knowing
something intellectually and actually
feeling it in your bones and really and
i think one of the things one of the
reasons why my youtube channel kind of
continued going was because i just
embraced the fact that my first 50 to
100 videos were just going to be awful
and i was like as soon as i can get
through those awful videos uh the more
then and kind of slowly improve over
time eventually i'll get actually good
at making videos so what i i guess my
question is was there
what was going in your going on in your
mind to take that from an intellectual
knowledge that
uh perfectionism is bad and shouldn't
stop me from doing this to actual like
actually making that guide your actions
in actually uploading those videos
because it's a pretty unusual thing to
do like those people have the thought of
i want to do x and very few of us
actually do the thing
basically like
i don't i don't think about it too much
i just i tell myself i'm gonna do the
thing and then i do it and
i see you laughing and you know my
girlfriend she always says to me nasser
you're a robot like you think like a
robot
um in the sense that
you know you don't
um
you don't think about how this is gonna
feel or how it's gonna turn out you just
do the thing
um and so once i told myself i was going
to make a video on the youcat verbal
reasoning section i would just make it
no matter how bad the video quality was
or the audio wasn't perfect because
there was a car outside or whatever
and i would just publish it yeah
i know it's super unrelatable and like
i'm i'm trying to better understand how
i think about these things um but a lot
of it really just is i told myself i
would do it and so then i did it yeah
yeah that makes sense that's how i think
as well uh yeah when we started doing a
youtuber academy i would start getting i
would i would get questions you know in
our first cohort like how did you bring
yourself to upload the videos
i was like huh
i mean it's
you know i i made it into
something that was not an option like
yeah exactly once a week i was going to
upload a video yeah and
when you decide that once a week you're
going to upload a video
then you just upload the video right
yeah and people are like well well no
because i still have all these feelings
of like fear and perfectionism and
anxiety and all this sort of stuff um
and it was very ideal that we had
someone on the team uh who you also know
um uh who was my assistant at the time
who now works for the youtuber academy
elizabeth who had much more of a
uh more
ten times more empathy than i did around
like what it's actually like
being a beginner and putting yourself
out there and she could relate to those
struggles a lot more than i could i was
just like managing upload the goddamn
video how hard could it be
i know i know and um honestly this
process of sort of reflecting on why i
make the decisions that i do and how i
feel about uploading videos or making
things is something i've really only
started quite recently um after in
september october time i started going
to therapy
and i genuinely felt like for the first
time in my life i started thinking about
why i'm doing the things that i'm doing
and how i feel about them because before
that it was just it was quite literally
you know just do the thing because you
said you were going to do it
and we can go into that a little bit
later
um but yeah it's uh
it's uh it's a process i think like
learning to identify how you feel about
it and why you feel that way and and
whatever okay i definitely want to come
back to the therapy thing and i
definitely want to come back to your
sort of like why you're still keen on
the medicine stuff which i think will be
interesting to talk about later so
you're in your second year you're 23
years old this is probably like four
years ago ish three years ago yeah four
years ago and you decide i'm gonna make
youtube videos and every week you bang
out some stuff that helps people get
into med school
what did the kind of trajectory of your
channel look like in those like early
days
um the trajectory was really slow
but
incredibly uh
sort of gratifying on a qualitative
level so quantitatively there weren't
very many views there weren't very many
comments uh or whatever but
qualitatively how i felt about making
the videos the sort of creative fun that
i had making them and the challenge for
myself learning these new skills of
editing filming recording publishing
whatever
and then also the feedback i was getting
from those small people who are watching
the videos was amazing i felt like the
qualitative feedback was exponential the
quantitative growth was extremely slow
and so for about a year and a half i
published a video every single week
and you know i would publish on thursday
at 8 30 in the morning and i still do
till this day um and so you know
wednesday nights i'd be staying up late
editing like whatever and my girlfriend
always say to me like nasa just just
upload the video on friday like why do
you have to do on thursday and be like
no i said i'm gonna do on thursday so it
has to go up on thursday and it goes
back to that thing if you know you just
said you were gonna do it so just do it
at that time anyways i'm going on a
tangent um
so i was uploading videos every single
week for about a year and a half and i
think at that time i had seven thousand
subscribers six thousand something like
after a year and a half after a year and
a half after making like 75-ish videos
one a week for 18 months yeah yeah it's
like good amount of seven thousand six
thousand subscribers something like that
yeah exactly um and then i posted a vlog
about me studying for a medical school
exam and that really blew up at the time
and that got like hundreds of thousands
of views within a couple of days and
then weeks
and brought i think like 30 000
subscribers to the channel or something
like that and that's why i felt like i
had my big break or whatever oh um okay
so it sounds like
the you know i've been doing a lot of
research on motivation these days for
the book that i'm working on um a lot of
uh a lot of the research suggests that
uh motivation is not a thing that you
generate before doing an action
motivation is the thing that comes after
you do the action and you see some small
level of success sure and so for you
it's like i'm gonna make the video
and then you're out there hustling
trying to get an individual one at a
time to watch that video that person is
giving you feedback and being like this
video was sick and then that that gives
you the the kind of dopamine hit to
continue making the videos yeah at the
same time as you're making the videos
you're personally having fun because
just the act of creation i think is an
inherently rewarding experience right
and for anything you know making a
pottery
wheel thingy or making a youtube video
or writing anything there's something
about creation that really i don't know
fulfills the soul in some capacity like
yeah you can say look i made that i made
that thing yeah it was just like it was
nothing and then i turned that footage
into something good
um and i guess
those like more
uh yeah
qualitative
markers of feedback qualitative drivers
kept you going even while the numbers
weren't necessarily like incredibly high
for sure and
you know the thing that i say to people
is if you just make a video every week
for two years and try and get a little
bit better like 100 guarantee that your
life will change i can't tell you when
it's gonna happen i can't tell you what
which video is going to go viral how
many views or how many numbers how many
how much revenue how many subscribers
you're gonna get yeah and i can 100
guarantee it will change your life yeah
whether it's in terms of like the skills
you learn or the people that you meet or
you know potentially at some point a
video might pop and now we're talking
yeah the youtube game is honestly 100
consistency i really think it's just
about doing the same thing over and over
again over a long enough period of time
until something happens someone notices
your video the algorithm notes is your
video whatever
but i just really think it's about
repetition repetition repetition
yeah so okay on that so on that note um
we all we we do often sometimes get
students in our in our youtuber academy
who
uh you know take the consistency mantra
to heart
all right cool i guess i'm just gonna
make videos and they make videos about
random topics talking about things that
they're interested in filming it with
crappy quality because there's like
consistency and improvement over time um
and
one one view that i've been thinking
about a lot recently is that consistency
alone is not the answer like there are
like other ingredients that go into
success
so for you and i guess if you were
giving advice to
i don't know like
people thinking of starting a youtube
channel or potentially like
having started a
something to do with content on social
media what are the elements other than
consistency that you think feed into the
success equation yeah as it were um
yeah i think i should probably rephrase
that consistency is a necessary
requirement whilst you're also
constantly trying to evolve and learn
and improve
consistency has to be there throughout
but as you said you're right it's not
enough um i think the main things
i mean youtube's also partially a game
you need to make content that people are
wanting to watch you need to make
content that you think is clickable that
might be shareable the algorithm might
pick up etc um and also that is
good to whatever the good standard is
and i think on youtube there definitely
is this sort of minimum
sorry there definitely is this sort of
minimum threshold of good and once
you've ticked that box it becomes less
important how good the video is right
the production quality once it reaches a
certain level anything past that is just
like okay well this is this is nice but
it doesn't need to be here you know
um
and so yeah the other things to kind of
focus on for me was just with every
video that i put out i wanted to do
something new and learn something
different whether that was a new
transition
i don't know adding music or a sound
effect or i don't know learning how to
crop in add text manipulate things
i just wanted to do something new and
you know part of that was what made it
so intellectually stimulating to keep on
going every single week because it was
really fun as we said before
um
we are consistency and constantly trying
to innovate and get better whatever get
better means uh you know incrementally
for you over time like how do you how do
you think about this this question of
like
[Music]
what what videos should i make next
okay
so
the videos that i make next are ones
that
i want to make
and then they need to appeal to who i
think my niche is or my target audience
so
there's a lot of videos that i upload
that i know from the get go are going to
tank in terms of numbers
comments views whatever
but they're videos that i think are
important and i think for the few people
who do watch it it is going to be
valuable
and so
if it meets that threshold then the
video is going to get made
um and obviously there's like a long
list and we move them back and forth all
the time and there's a balance of what's
going to go out next but um yeah i need
to think that i'm going to enjoy making
this video and that there's going to be
some value for the people who watch it
and then after that it becomes about
it becomes more about how do we frame
this in a way that's clickable that
people will want to watch um etc
as opposed to starting from
what's the most clickable what do people
want to watch
it's a bounce it's not so black and
white
so
okay so let's say you
decide you want to do a video exploring
your menswear wardrobe because you think
it's a sort of video that would appeal
to someone like me
but it's not really within your core
focus of your channel to be doing
menswear content
would you do the menswear video
following this formula of like i think
this will be valuable to some people
like ali who needs menswear advice or
would you be like uh it it's not
sufficiently valuable to the people that
i think are following my channel i.e
maybe medics maybe students like
whatever uh sort of
pseudo avatar you have in your mind and
therefore i'm not going to do the
menswear video
no i don't think so i would i would
still do the menswear video
if i want if i thought it was going to
be fun okay and it wasn't going to be
the biggest lift as you would say um
i mean this is kind of like when i made
a 20 minute video about coffee and i was
just like drinking coffee from five or
six different methods of like grinding
the beans or whatever i made a video
about um how to publish academic
research which like is very pretty
how to take a patient history i did
recently which you know my channel is
about medical school
about studying yeah um
medical educational video yeah
meta medicine video yeah um so you know
i knew it wasn't going to do well in
terms of like numbers and algorithm but
i was like this is a valuable video that
i wish i had when i was in my first and
second year i think it'll be fun to make
let me make it
um so yeah something like the wardrobe
video i've actually wanted to do for a
while and multiple sponsors have come
and gone saying make a video about you
know uh your clothing
but uh it's always been in my head too
big of a lift to do and i also don't
really think i'm that knowledgeable
about clothes and fashion and menswear
and things like that
um i try my best but i don't think i'm
knowledgeable enough to speak about it
like in a video so it sounds like you're
not limiting yourself based on who you
think your target audience is
particularly no not at all because the
most important thing is that i make a
video each week i do
what the video is on isn't as important
as the fact that i just put one out i
just want to be creating content um why
to be honest um i really really enjoy it
and i feel like i've kind of reached
this point where i'm on a hamster wheel
and we can we can talk about this more
later i think it's important as well
where there's almost
there's so much less thought involved
now than at the beginning now it's just
like the wheel is turning you know
inject all the different ingredients and
components that go into making a video
and each week by thursday there will be
one uploaded
um and so i've kind of been on this
hamster wheel for about four years now
of pumping out a video every single week
um something that i plan to sort of
scale back and change a little bit um
probably in a couple of months when i
graduated medical school
um
but yeah i forgot how we got into this
hamster wheel
i i kind of asked why like what's the
what's the point of being on the hamster
wheel yeah like why do you want to um
stick to this like you've been doing it
for four years now yeah yeah so
at its core it's fun it's something that
i enjoy and evidently it seems to
provide value to other people um and i
think that constant feedback of
uh for me to know that it is somehow
useful for others is the major driving
port a major driving point and after
that it's fun and after that i told
myself i was gonna upload a video every
single week and so i do
okay
what would happen if you didn't one day
um
probably nothing but i think i'm kind of
so i'm a really goal-oriented person
okay um as you might imagine and um kind
of the next goal that i had the next big
goals that i have in my life are to
graduate medical school and to hit a
million subscribers on this youtube
channel and so those are kind of the
goals that i'm working towards before i
make a big change or switch up this like
once a week routine or the type of
content that i'm making and things like
that i'm kind of like let me just keep
things as they are right now because i
have a lot to focus on with medical
school and whatever
um and once we reach that big goal i can
like make a big change
okay
okay
i want to push back on this goal thing
because so so my issue with goals i
think we talked about
this before is that when you set a goal
then
so so for example if if i imagine for
you if i was i don't know your youtube
growth coach or something and you told
me my goal is to hit a million
subscribers i'd be like okay cool let's
figure out what your most viral videos
are the ones that have brought in the
most subscribers
and then i'd be like why are you making
these like random videos that you're
doing for fun why don't we just optimize
like imagine if you just made one viral
video a month
instead of for non-viral videos a month
surely we'd get you to the million
subscribers faster yeah and then but
this so
if any and and if i had a goal of a
million subscribers and someone said
that to me i think
oh okay but the million subscribers is
not the point there are there there is
something else going on here that the i
just want to hit a million subscribers
does not quite
embody if you get what i mean so i'm i'm
very much like you i i set um
what you describe as like input goals so
the actual goal isn't to reach a million
subscribers the it's the idea that in a
couple of months somewhere here or there
i'm probably going to pass a million
subscribers at that point i'm going to
make a big change
um but in terms of how we get there yes
i agree with you if i just focus on
making one viral video then i might get
there a lot faster
but then that doesn't sort of follow the
rule of let me make the content that i
actually want to make
for example i know for example that
vlogs will happen to perform better on
my channel um other videos about like
hardcore focus and studying things like
that but then when i sit down
like last week and i'm like what video
am i gonna make next week that's not
really what's at the forefront of my
mind what gets me excited to pick up a
camera and so i won't make that video
okay um
yeah so it's like it sounds like it's
some combination of you have goals but
you also have standards
i have loads of goals you have your own
personal preferences of i want to hit a
million subscribers but i want to do it
on my terms i don't want to just make
vlogs that will pander to the audience
or whatever you want for sure for sure
this whole youtube thing is only still
going because i still find it fun and i
think if i was the more and more this
becomes like a job the more and more i
start to focus on the numbers and trying
to make videos that will perform well
and things like that the less and less
fun this becomes and i'm really scared
of that happening so i try to stay away
from it and do that as little as
possible interesting interesting like
yeah this this just gels so much with my
own personal experience and a bunch of a
bunch of research i've been doing into
like intrinsic and extrinsic motivation
as well
where initially when we start doing
stuff like for example when we're kids
we're do we're doing things because
they're fun for the pure joy of doing
the thing and then at some point grades
coming comes into the mix and we start
doing things because it will get us a
better grade i think medics are
particularly prone to this so i will
only do the thing if it will get me the
appropriate number of cv points and
pubmed reference paper that will give me
two extra points for my freaking fpass
application or my sd3 application eight
years down the line etc
are like this very goal oriented
extrinsically motivated way of doing
stuff
um and a bunch of the the the research
on motivation as you as you probably
know says that when you add in extrinsic
motivation it does in fact tend to crowd
out intrinsic motivation 100 and so you
know our mutual friend jack he and i
were talking the other day um he's also
a youtuber was talking about how when
when he and i were
making videos for fun they were fun but
when you switch to making videos for
your job suddenly there's something
about it while you're doing the same 100
but it just becomes not fun and now
you're like
i was i used to look forward to going
home from work to make a video and now i
look forward to doing anything else so i
don't have to make a video what the
hell's going on there like yeah yeah
what's been your experience
it's when it stops being on your own
terms and like this is part of the
reason why we take on so few
sponsorships i mean if you look on my
channel i really do sponsorships so
rarely and a really big driver for that
is that as soon as a sponsor is attached
to the video it suddenly becomes this
huge chore yeah it's not working
yeah and it has a deadline and they want
to review it and they have their
comments and this and that and there's
negotiation and back and forth
and then it stops becoming about i'm
making this video because i'm doing this
for fun and hopefully other people are
going to find value in it it becomes
like a job
and so
yeah that's part of the reason we try
and we just do them every single day
every single week and don't attach that
many sponsors to the videos yeah yeah
practically speaking yes when for
example
a channel of your size you could be
making ten thousand dollars for a video
sponsor says ten thousand dollars now
sir for a video
that's a that's a that's a decent chunk
of money
and how do you
decide how do i know i'm gonna say no to
ten thousand dollars because i want to
not have a deadline i want to not have
fun i don't want to bother sending a few
emails well what's going on in your mind
it's a very good question um and it's
something that i i do struggle with and
think about kind of often
i think the thing is um
these youtube videos that i make every
single week at the end of the day this
is a hobby for me this is something that
i do for fun
my main priority in life and when i'm
working towards my end goals is a career
in medicine and that is where the
majority of my focus is
and where i want my future to go
the fact that i make these videos and i
find them fun and that they make money
as well is like an incredible bonus it
is very hard to do that where you turn
down money uh when you know you could so
easily right but then there's also so
many prerequisites to taking on a
sponsor which is like it needs to be
valuable for me it needs to be valuable
to my audience he needs to fit in with
the content and those don't come around
very often either
there's definitely enough to fill the
videos but um turning down a sponsor
because you want to keep this as a fun
hobby and keep the longevity of it it's
kind of like a long-term thinking of if
i was to accept a bunch of sponsors yeah
i'd probably make a lot of money right
now but i'd burn up more quickly and i
wouldn't find this fun in like six
months time
but if i sort of take it at my own pace
then there's probably more longevity in
it and i can keep this online presence
wherever it takes me and whatever use it
has in the future
for longer and that's kind of the
trade-off that i'm investing that's a
large amount of self-awareness to
recognize that for you taking a 10k
sponsorship will be more likely to lead
to burnout etc further down the line how
did you arrive at that this is this is
this is where you're at well i i've
experienced how much it sucks the fun
out of this whole youtube thing to have
sponsors involved um and you know even
when we've tried moving to agencies that
are supposed to you know take off a lot
of the heavy lifting around sponsors and
things like that at the end of the day a
lot of it comes down to you at the end
you know you need to put in the work you
need to write the script for it you need
to film it you need to edit it or
whatever
um
so it just yeah it sucks the life out of
the thing and this is not my job this is
quite literally something i do part-time
for fun and so if i was to make it my
full-time job that's a separate story um
but it's not kind of where i want my
future to go
um my future is still set on medicine ah
okay i think that segways us very nicely
why is your future still set on medicine
um it's okay so i'll just say kind of
the the bare case for medicine as it
were
to use the sort of finance investing
crypto analogy is that
long hours a large like long amount of
training uh nhs is understaffed uh life
as a doctor is not that amazing if you
speak to a lot of doctors and you ask
them would you
would you rather be a youtuber at least
when i do they would often say
hell i'd rather do anything rather than
medicine etc etc um
bold case for being a youtuber is you'd
make more money you'd have more autonomy
you'd possibly have more fun you'd spend
a lot less time working
how how do you so
i balanced those factors and it led me
to the conclusion of quit medicine be a
full-time youtuber for now slash
entrepreneur content creator internet
whatever
what is it about medicine that makes you
so like
yeah this is this is me yeah um
i think let me preface this with
something that one of my really close
friends says which is um
i reserve the right to change my opinion
and change my mind in light of new
evidence so having said that yeah um
yeah i completely agree with everything
you said when i think of my future job
working as a doctor and when i talk to
doctors on the wards everything is
negative and that's really soul crushing
it's hard questioning it sounds
it doesn't sound like fun you know based
on the long hours understaffed
overworked stressed you know barely
getting sleep whatever
um
and so i'm not looking forward to that
side of it very much
the truth is i don't i don't think i
could do anything else that would
provide me with the same amount of
satisfaction and gratification as i
would being a doctor and i think even if
i was to be a full-time youtuber or have
my own business or work in some other
industry i wouldn't get that same level
of satisfaction that i'm sort of chasing
and craving in my life
the
the sort of goals that i have for my
professional career are to be doing
something that i enjoy that i think
brings value to other people and
obviously there's tons of jobs you can
do that bring value to other people what
you're doing is bringing tons of value
to other people and you're not a doctor
anymore um
but you know it's a personal thing
obviously at the end of the day but i i
think that i wouldn't find anything more
satisfying or more gratifying than
caring for patients and working in a
hospital okay but your reserve the right
to change your mind of course yeah
absolutely because i always say right
this is all fine and well while i'm a
medical student being a medical student
is you know down here in terms of
responsibilities and work being down
here in terms of responsibility and work
and being an actual doctor is an entire
other ball game right
so only when i start working am i going
to be able to say yes i'm happy doing
this even with all the negatives that
are going on and that's where i reserve
the rights change my opinion comes in
because i don't know what it's going to
be like when i start working but i have
hope i have faith
that um
it's all going to go well what is it
about being so i yeah sort of uh take a
fully fully accepted caveat that
you're a medical student the levels of
idealism of a medical student are four
orders of magnitude compared to the
levels of idealism once you actually
start working as a doctor yeah but i'm
curious what like
what is it that you think
is will like for you will would would be
satisfying about the medicine thing
compared to for example being a teacher
or
running a business or continuing to do
your youtube thing yeah
i think like um being a teacher or being
in education whether that's in person or
sort of in an online way like you kind
of do now um has a lot of the same sort
of satisfying parts of being a doctor
and that you're educating your patients
you're empowering them and informing
them about their own health and other
people's health and things like that
um i think a big part of it that kind of
attracts me is the like high stakes
aspect or like the intensity aspect of
it so you know teaching someone about a
certain topic is you know it's going to
be gratifying and satisfying or whatever
but changing someone's health or helping
them in a time of like pain or need or
something like that
they're both very good but one of them i
think is like a lot more intense yeah
and i think that intensity i don't think
it necessarily makes it better or worse
than the other one
but it comes along with a different set
of like emotions and satisfaction i
think yes that's very true
that was one of the things that
kept me in
thinking
more about medicine for longer because
unlike for the for the last many years
people have been saying hey quit this
medicine thing do the youtube thing
and there was something about like i'm i
thrived off of the intensity of like a
cardiac arrest or like you know these
high octane specialties where there's a
lot going on
and did i enjoyed a lot less the more
chill specialties like older psychiatry
for example where or like gp to an
extent where it's like broadly clinic
based and it's yeah it's a bit less
adrenaline field and it sounds like
you're of a similar
cut from a summer cloth yeah exactly i
think i want to push away from like
clinical specialties and be a bit more
involved in the hospital um
i'm not the biggest fan of ward-based
medicine how it is for junior doctors it
seems like we're glorified
administrators or admins at the end of
the day from what i've heard um and seen
but um but yeah i think it's what you
said like there's a level of sort of
this is serious you need to be at the
top of your game when you're doing it
that i don't think necessarily exists in
other professions that also involve
teaching and helping people yeah
yeah i think that's yeah that's very
much a personal choice of like
do you thrive on the stress or do you
fold under the stress
as an individual
and yeah in fairness if i i
haven't thought in these terms for a
while but if i think of my friends who
seem to genuinely enjoy medicine they
are all the thrivers under stress type
people
and if i think of my friends who
will occasionally say hey are you
looking to hire someone
they tend to be the not a fan of stress
kind of people part of it is also like
this deeply ingrained sort of
thinking that is in my head and i guess
of people in my generation as well that
like in order to have success in order
to have happiness in order to whatever
you need to be working hard you need to
be in a high stress environment you need
to be pushing yourself um which is
probably not true at all but it's kind
of like an intrinsic feeling of like you
want to be doing something that's
intense not necessarily stressful but
like get your blood going
yeah there's definitely like i've been
doing a bunch of reading into this as
well this uh culture of all this
narrative that
hard work is itself a virtue
and i think this is a very
it's a very like pervasive um
thing and it's not necessarily always
bad all the time
but
i've begun to think uh
how to write a lot about like where this
comes from the whole like 1500's the
protestant work ethic the idea that
working hard is itself a virtue that
brings you closer to god and it's not
just about the fruits of your labor it's
also about how hard you work for it
and
there's this you know there's a really
good book um by paul miller oh
i've got a lot of copies there gives you
a copy of this it's sick the pathless
path imagining a new story for work and
life where he used to be like a
management consultant new york et cetera
et cetera and then
ended up uh leaving his job after a few
years and kind of massively cutting down
his salary just doing a little freelance
stuff here and there and just doing the
whole slow living exploring the world
and he writes a lot about this
kind of uh
history of workism and where the idea
that hard work is a virtue comes from
and i think it's all it's all very
interesting and it's something that i'm
grappling with
as well
um
because yeah it i think it's definitely
something that's ingrained in us to some
extent maybe not so much in people who
are like five years or so younger than
us but certainly for me and a lot of my
friend group and how my parents raised
me it's like you need to work hard why
do you need to work hard well just
because like you know that's what you do
like you go to uni then you work hard
and you support your family and
um and you know that's how you thrive um
and so a lot of like sitting down and
studying or going to work is just this
is what i'm supposed to do it's this
natural drive that's kind of within us i
think if we all took a step back and
think about it a little bit more we'd
realize this probably isn't the case and
we shouldn't think of it like that um
but i just feel like something deeply
ingrained inside um
you mentioned that maybe not for people
five years younger than us what
like you probably speak to students who
are like in their
late teens early 20s what
what's their life
a huge generalization incoming but
people of my parents age and maybe our
grandparents age their whole sort of
life
goals was
go to university get a good job and then
you've made it in life you are
successful you have your career you have
your family you're good that's what
you're supposed to do right
whereas i feel like for a lot of people
our age now and younger that isn't where
the primary source of happiness is
coming from i think people want to have
a wider impact they want to
focus a lot more on their social life on
their personal life and then their job
is just kind of something that they do
to sustain themselves whereas in the
past the job was the one thing that you
did kind of mental health wasn't
important social life wasn't important
it was all about sacrifice sacrifice
sacrifice big generalization
and so yeah i think people who are a bit
younger than us
place a bigger importance on mental
health and having fun and
balance in their life than maybe someone
who has come like myself who's come from
a migrant family and thinks you know i
need to get my education need to get a
good job need to have a family blah blah
blah
yeah one of the things that paul miller
talks about in the book um and he's got
a tweet thread about this is the
accidental threads oh that's so good
there's like a good condensation of like
what you know sometimes in the book um
the the accidental meaning hypothesis
well the idea there is that for our
parents generation um
going to university getting that good
job staying with ibm for 50 years
working your way up getting the company
car and the health insurance
was in fact a recipe for a meaningful
life
back when we lived out in where when we
lived in the suburbs the people were
very involved in the community
uh controversial point but like the
traditional family unit was a bit more
of a thing you would go to church on
sundays you would have like you would
you would know who your neighbors are
and if you followed that path just by
virtue of the fact that that was your
life setup life felt pretty meaningful
like you have community you have family
you have a social life by default um
nowadays where we live in a bigger
sporting apartment buildings we have no
idea who the hell and neighbors are
fewer fewer people are for example
living with their families and living in
their local communities and getting
involved with the local communities and
it's all about like how do i get ahead
in my career et cetera et cetera
now the model of oh i'll just work at
the same job for 40 years no longer
leads to accidental
meaningful fulfilling life yeah and now
he's and therefore we have to think
harder about what are the elements of a
meaningful and fulfilling life that we
just don't have by default and
incorporating them actively into our
life rather than passively by default
yeah yeah i think our parents and
grandparents had the right idea because
as you said you know that's how society
was that's how the world was if you
wanted a meaningful life that is what
you had to do i'm not saying they were
wrong i just think now if you follow
that same recipe then you won't
necessarily achieve the same things
definitely definitely so how do you
think that how do you think about that
for yourself when it comes to medicine
how do you think of your future korean
medicine hypothesizing will
lead into this idea of a meaningful life
what does that mean to you
i think to be honest a lot of it is um
i've set this goal for myself or i'm on
this path of becoming a doctor and hence
i'm just on the treadmill until i become
a doctor and then i'm gonna think about
the next steps you know i mean like if i
think about it too hard everything
becomes everything becomes stressful and
it becomes too much it comes too much to
handle you know let me just focus on one
thing at a time yeah
um so you know after i graduate uh
medicine i just really want to see what
the job is actually like for the first
two years this is my sort of big
goal for the next two years is to find
out what does it mean to actually be a
doctor working day in and day out how am
i going to feel am i going to have the
impact that i think i'm going to have
right now is it going to be as
satisfying and fulfilling as i think
it's going to be
and then after that i can make decisions
on you know what i want to do next or if
i want to change but until then i think
it would be very hard and just really
speculative more than anything
how do i think medicine is going to fit
into my life
in terms of providing me with happiness
and accomplishment
again it's it's about what i think it's
going to give me you know i don't
actually know because i haven't worked
i've talked to people and i've been
there but i don't i don't know
i hope that it will give me all those
things um and i have faith that it will
touch wood
yeah i think i think this is a really
healthy way of looking at things like in
a way you're not
you know the whole like simon sinek
start with why stuff like why are you
really doing that i i've always i've
always kind of felt that especially for
making decisions about career and about
life and these sort of big decisions
especially when you're young it's
actually very hard to start with why and
be like why am i actually doing this
what's my goal what's my broader purpose
what's what's the point and it gets you
into this mode of thinking huh
i really don't want to think about this
right now i just want to know definitely
not let's let's worry about this a
little bit later and so i think some
level of introspection is good to be but
i think i think the way you're
approaching it is absolutely sick where
you're like okay my hypothesis is that
working in medicine will lead to a
meaningful life because of a b c d and e
um and i'm going to test the hypothesis
over the next two years exactly and then
i'll focus on that and then i'll worry
about it further further down the line
exactly you're not like up and on like
oh my god like i had a bad day on the
wards today as a fourth year medical
student or whatever therefore
it wasn't really for me like never never
never yeah um
there's this there's this idea of um not
being results oriented so i don't mean
results as in like getting good grades
or things like that i mean not being
outcome oriented so this is a term that
comes from poker and when you play poker
and um you make a
so when you're playing poker and you
make a call or you or you raise or you
fold or whatever
you are making a action now that action
you don't know whether it was the right
action or the wrong action until um the
cards come out and you know whether you
won or lost but at the time when you
made that decision there is a
mathematically correct response for you
to make so you make the response that is
best and then there's variance and
there's luck involved as to whether that
actually results in you winning or
losing right
so if you make that correct decision at
the beginning i think the outcome is
absolutely irrelevant and this is a huge
philosophy that i live my life by
i just tell myself make the best
decision that you can with the
information that you have right now
whatever happens after that could be
good could be bad based on that decision
but you did the right thing at the time
and that lifts all this weight off my
shoulders of did i make the right
decision should i have done this should
i have done that there's no questioning
involved i just i just made the decision
that i did with the information i had at
the time and i can't ask myself if
anything else you know yeah
that's so good i love that um
though the quote that i found myself
thinking about a lot which relates to
that is
i think it's a quote from like buddhism
or something uh or some other eastern
tradition uh which is a total commitment
to the process total equanimity about
the outcome
um and it's like i'm gonna do what i can
i'm gonna make the best decision i can
i'm gonna put the effort into it that i
can while having fun
and who cares what the outcome is
and i remember this sort of when i
you know working working on the book
part of me wants it to be a new york
times bestseller and all that stuff
stuff obviously but that's an outcome
and that's an outcome that i have no
control over yeah i'm going to commit to
the process i'm going to show up and do
my best and then the outcome is in god's
hands exactly so it's all good like i
suddenly don't need to worry about the
[ __ ] anymore right exactly you don't
have to think about what i can yeah it's
glorious
100 it sounds strange to say this out
loud but i make as few decisions as i
can in my day i don't really think about
things i just tell myself what i'm going
to do based on what i think is the best
action and then i go do it because if i
think about it too hard then you start
thinking about should i have done this
should i've done that why am i doing
this how do i feel about it etc i think
it really impedes the process and takes
away from whatever your end goal is
and you know being introspective and
reflective as you were talking about
before is something that i really admire
in people because it's something that i
haven't been able to do for pretty much
all my life
and now i'm doing it a little bit more
recently um
but to to a certain extent i think it's
good too much of it and overthinking
yeah it's also bad you need a good
balance
um
so yeah so this segues nicely into
therapy yeah so let's do it tell me more
tell me more so so what happened um i
was at the end of my fourth year of
medical school
i kind of
did summer
and then came back to medical school
and kind of before i knew it i just
found myself like not wanting to get out
of bed all right which is something i've
never experienced before and i really
pride myself on being a consistently
happy person nothing gets me down like
everything is water under the bridge
brush things off my shoulder whatever
like as we said like i don't think about
things too hard whatever the outcome is
the outcome is i made the best decision
so you know like i'm constantly happy
pretty much like touchwood anyways we
got to this point where um i kind of was
like
yeah just like feeling like i wasn't
enjoying my day as much as i should and
suddenly i wasn't getting up on my first
alarm ringing and i was getting up on my
like third or fifth and i was like
what's going on here
by an absolute stroke of luck at the
same time a company that provides mental
counseling and therapy services had
reached out to me and said we want to
sponsor a video on the channel
so i said okay cool that's great i'm
making a video about burnout
that's a great fit why don't you give me
access to the platform so i can test it
out and use it and these two things were
happening at the same time i hadn't this
is all in retrospect that i realized you
know i wasn't feeling that good
so we set up like the first therapy
session
and i remember before going i was on the
phone to my girlfriend and i was like
babe like what am i going to say like
what am i going to talk about to this
person like they're just a random person
they don't know me i don't have anything
like life is good
um
and we we start the call
and before i knew it i was just rambling
rambling rambling about all these things
that i was getting off of my chest that
i had been feeling all these years and
all this time that i'd literally not
just taken the time to stop and think
about
and i was i was thinking to myself like
nasser you're doing all of these things
in your life keeping yourself busy like
trying to make others happy and trying
to help other people and you didn't take
a second to think about this stuff like
why did you wait so long
and it was kind of this place where i
was living in like ignorance is bliss
just don't think about the why don't
think about how you're feeling about it
x1 said just get the thing done
and i wasn't reflecting on kind of
anything that was happening in my life
and
through the course of like a couple of
therapy sessions
i felt like i was reflecting a lot more
on how i was feeling about medical
school about the youtube channel about
my family about life my girlfriend you
know everything and it kind of opened up
this part of my brain that i had never
used before or thought about before
which is you know you can think about
the things that you're doing and you can
acknowledge how it makes you feel
um and yeah it's been fun it's been
really fantastic i kind of think as the
last year as pre-therapy and post
therapy in terms of like how i live my
life
interesting yeah sorry thank you big
ramble thank you being so open about
this this is fantastic stuff yeah for
sure you know i've been saying all this
time to like to friends to family to
patients like you know like seek mental
health services do this do that um and
so you know if i'm advocating for people
to go to this like i should be talking
about it quite openly as well um
and yeah so what have been
some of the changes
in your life pre and post therapy
um
i think kind of the biggest one is i'm
trying to be a bit less of a like robot
in terms of uh thinking and my actions
but most importantly time management
okay so i am someone who
prides myself a lot on my time
management and i think that i balance a
lot of things in my life really well
um and it all like kind of comes
naturally to me and and it all goes well
the sort of downside to that is that
um i'm constantly working you know i'm
constantly like moving from one thing to
the next and it's really difficult to
stay in the moment you know if we were
doing this pre-therapy i'd be thinking
about okay as soon as i leave this this
podcast i'm gonna go home i'm gonna have
a ten minute coffee break then i'm gonna
sit down for half an hour and i'm gonna
work on my emails and then i'm gonna
have a two hour study cess with kenji
and georgina my parents are gonna come
we're gonna go for dinner i wouldn't be
thinking about us in this moment right
now i would always be thinking about
what's next what sex what's next and i
used to keep track of every single thing
i did in my life i like i could tell you
how long it takes for me to do any task
walk from here to there go to the
bathroom make a tea versus a coffee make
this food versus that food you know i
was just very hyper focused on time
um and kind of through therapy i've
realized that i can still complete
everything i want to do in my life
without necessarily sort of working on
the to-do list up until i go to sleep at
midnight or you know constantly
squeezing in little bits of work on the
bus on the train when i'm walking things
like that i've taken like a much more
relaxed attitude towards life um which
has been amazing would highly recommend
for anyone who thinks they might benefit
from therapy to give it a try okay wow
sorry those are no no this is great
that's that's all very interesting okay
um i have heard people say things to
that effect of like
um for example
we
did an interview with julian hearn the
founder of huel yes and
similarly with james hoffman the coffee
challenge who you're probably probably
familiar with yeah and one thing i'm
always intrigued by is to what extent is
it that the hustle hustle mind the kind
of i'm gonna
have coffee rather than tea because tea
takes an extra three minutes to brew and
i can't be asked to wait three minutes
because i have to work on my to-do list
to what extent was that a thought
process that served you when you were
young and quote not successful um
or is it that now that you're a little
bit more enlightened around the whole
work-life balance hustle culture not not
amazing type thing
is
is that a kind of privileged position to
have to be able to be like oh actually i
can smell the roses whereas back in the
day when you were struggling to make
ends meet your or you know whatever that
looks like for you smelling the roses
was a luxury you can afford
yeah so
really good point to to make is that
like i largely attribute the success of
my youtube channel and my success in
medical school and in my relationships
and whatever um
obviously there's a lot of luck involved
and a lot of things have gone my way i'm
extremely privileged to begin with and
with everything that's happened so far
but a lot of that is because of that
really hard work so had i not been so
obsessed about my time management and
working in every little pocket that i
had staying up late sacrificing sleep
sacrificing social life meetings with
friends whatever
i really don't think i could have ended
up in the position that i'm in
there's a lot of things involved luck is
most certainly very involved
but without that kind of hard work i
wouldn't be able to be here and so i
don't regret doing any of those things
and i think they were a necessary
ingredient in the concoction that puts
me in the place that i am today
but it's kind of what i talked about
before i feel like i've been on this
hamster wheel for so so long and i've
reached the level of success infinitely
bigger than i thought i would ever have
right to think i'm gonna hit a million
subscribers soon is absolutely
ridiculous right when i reached 10 000
the numbers stopped making sense and
then you get your silver plaque and
you're like okay this symbolizes a
hundred thousand
like
i'm more successful
in terms of youtube numbers and whatever
than i would ever hope to be i've made
it right if i quit today i would be
happy like i'm good
um and so i've reached that level of
success where i feel like or success in
terms of uh this
where i feel like i can take that step
back now and say to myself you know and
also like you did the hard work you did
the thing yeah
now you can realize maybe you can take a
step back and sort of live a little bit
more slow and relaxed interesting if you
had your time again
would you
have wanted to live more
slow and relaxed
uh
maybe at the expense of some quote
growth
or
would you be
would you
would you do all again and sort of treat
your 20 early 20s as like uh okay this
is hustle season and now i'm in chill
season kind of vibe uh i think i think i
would definitely do everything the same
the reason is that i thoroughly enjoyed
the whole process i wasn't going through
that time you know
like i said sleepless nights and this
and that i wasn't going through all of
that wishing that i had more sleep or
wishing that i was staying up late
because i was excited about posting the
video the next day you know
um and so i really enjoyed that whole
process and i i wouldn't change it going
back the only thing i would do really is
study less for my university in the
earlier years like first and second year
in both degrees because i just
overworked during that time when i
didn't really necessarily need to
um
but otherwise no like the hard the the
work ethic and the discipline i think is
necessary yeah i like that so it's like
um there's this other quote that i came
across which was
along the lines of
uh
insofar as you enjoy it there is nothing
wrong with working really hard
and it's when you start finding yourself
not enjoying it that you can reassess be
like okay hang on it's a bit weird that
i don't want to get out of bed now like
i'm supposed to be the guy that's like
freaking having an amazing time doing
all the things winning on all the fronts
now something has changed oops something
has changed and therefore i don't really
enjoy anymore let me examine that and in
a way it
like lets go go
and sometimes you do have to push
yourself a little bit too far to
recognize why that limit where that line
is then you take a step back you're like
okay cool that's that's reasonable
yeah i am
i really think to sort of achieve
um a level of success whatever that
means in any field that you're in you do
have to put in that extra work harder
than the person who's sitting next to
you you know a lot of luck and privilege
is involved obviously um but i do think
that at the end of the day without the
hard work no matter how much luck and
privilege you have you're not going to
get to that point
and so i recently made a video about
toxic productivity because
um i i came to the conclusion that a lot
of the videos on my channel would fall
under the toxic productivity category so
long study sessions yeah how i started
14 hours a day yeah i mean that kind of
stuff all i talk about is like time
management and studying and productivity
right yeah and in that video the the
case that i try to make is that first of
all this is what i'm actually doing i'm
not actually sleeping all day and just
making these videos this is what i'm
actually doing and the only reason that
i'm doing it is because i'm enjoying it
no one's no one's sitting here with a
gun to my head saying that's her work
harder and be more aware of your time
management these are things that i do
because i enjoy them and i'm sharing
them because i think that other people
might find value in them and if you do
then that's fantastic and if you don't
you don't have to watch this video you
don't have to
you know
take part in this if if this content is
something that you don't want to consume
then like that's completely fair enough
i understand where you're coming from
this really isn't for everyone and so
yeah like it should be okay as long as
you enjoy it yeah right
yeah there's like this balance between
you know the internet people want you to
be authentic
but only authentic insofar as it ticks
the boxes that society has decided in
that given season is an appropriate
amount of work and life to have yeah
exactly right yeah had we been making
these videos like 50 years ago it would
just be all praise about hard work and
dedication and work ethic and motivation
but today most people feel like actually
no this is negative this is bad and
that's fair enough people are entitled
to feel that way but it doesn't mean
that there's something inherently wrong
with the videos that we're making that's
the point that i that i'm trying to make
yeah it's a good place to be so are you
still going ongoing with the therapy
thing or was it like a few sessions
so yeah so it was an eight-week thing
and i kind of treated it like
an essay or an assignment or a game or
something throughout the whole therapy
session i would just be taking notes
like frantically on all the important
points and at the end i would make
myself an action plan yeah and then
during the week i would work on the
action plan and make sure that i was
actually doing the things that were
going to help me in some way shape or
form so let's say in therapy session one
we would identify x or y problem i would
think about how can i fix xor problem
work on it during the week and then
report back i fixed x i haven't haven't
quite fixed y let's work on that a
little bit more yeah it's very something
like productivity bro way of dealing
with therapy it is it is but i can't
imagine doing it any other way yeah and
i think i think half of therapy
is uh talking someone else listening to
them um having them you know tell you
things the other half is you need to put
in some amount of work to try and change
the things that you're unhappy with or
um
or you know whatever it is that you need
to do
so i think you need a little bit of both
for sure okay so we were talking about
like your pre and post therapy self and
you said one of the things definitely is
that you've taken taken the foot of the
gas a little bit shall we say um that
reminds me of a story that derek sivers
writes about in his book i think it's in
anything you want
where he talks about how he would always
go for a cycle every day
and
it would take him 40 minutes to go and
he'd be sweating at the end of it and
he'd be like cool i need to need to make
my time it's 40 minutes then one day he
decided you know what i'm just going to
enjoy the cycle right it's like oh cool
like oh it's spanning the roses on the
way and picking up a little pebble and
like you know just like actually
enjoying the cycle ride and he gets back
he looks at the clock and it's 42
minutes and he's like damn was i really
huffing and puffing and wearing myself
out for the sake of two extra minutes
that seems a bit weird
that's a really excellent analogy of how
i feel pre and post therapy i'm still
achieving the same things i'm just
taking it a little bit more relaxed and
enjoying myself a little bit more and
really the amount of output that i'm
losing is minimal and that's the
realization that i've had which i didn't
have before i was under the assumption
that
you know i just have to continue working
up until the point that i go to sleep
because every night when i go to sleep i
look at my to-do list and there's 10
items on there and i'm like well i could
probably bang out two of these right now
before i go to bed or i can leave them
all tomorrow the obvious choice is to
bang two of these before i go to bed
let's get that done
nowadays so
post therapy right or during therapy for
the first time in my life i sat down in
bed and i watched a movie on netflix by
myself up until that point yeah yeah
right which which sounds crazy right i
mean you know my girlfriend's been
telling me to do this forever my friends
have been telling me to do this forever
and i would always think to myself like
why would i do that when i could work on
my to-do list like it's not about being
unproductive it's just i wanted to do
the other things like i have this to-do
list of things that i genuinely enjoy
let me get some of them done yeah and so
now i just watch a movie before i go to
bed
and i do those two tasks in the morning
instead of the night before and i just
relax at the end of the day and unwind
like why do i need to be on this
constant hamster wheel of running
running running doing all this time
management stuff
i can just take a bit of a step back and
like you said it will take me 42 minutes
instead of 40
and it's not the end of the world and
that's kind of the change that i'm going
through now
have you come across a 4 000 weeks by
oliver berkman
you would enjoy it it's uh we've got it
here somewhere uh it's great it's like
uh sort of 2022 2021 uh productivity
book in inverted commerce but it's it's
not really about productivity it's it's
more it's more like a philosophical
approach to time management recognizing
that four thousand weeks is roughly the
amount of time we have on this earth
and uh
once we accept the finitude of existence
and our own mortality we stop uh trying
to cram all these things and juggle all
these balls and we recognize that there
genuinely isn't enough time for all the
important things and therefore something
they're just gonna have to be put in the
bin for now
and uh it's a very liberating and
interesting read uh would recommend and
for anyone listening we have an
interview with oliver burkman which will
also be linked in the in the show notes
down below shameless plug very nice um
but yeah so i've i found myself having
similar realizations where
i
used to feel bad about like not replying
to people and now i don't feel bad about
replying to people unlike whatsapp or
emails and stuff and emails friends or
people on the internet watch your stuff
both to an extent like friends i still
feel a little bit bad because like it's
a friendship to maintain and i try not
to apply productivity bro lends to
friendships um but even friends to an
extent to be honest like i used to feel
guilty that oh i have these 80 unread
whatsapps and it's all people friends of
mine like even like yeah friends who i
should be replying to and i know i want
to reply to them but like
ugh i just can't bring myself to make
the time to to do this thing
and
now i guess what i've accepted is just
like yeah i'm just
that's okay like
maybe i will lose out on one or two
friendships because i was not
sufficiently good at replying to
whatsapp messages but actually that's
okay that's a sacrifice i'm willing to
make and the amount of extra stress it
adds to my life to feel the need to
maintain a a i don't know two hour
response time or to whatsapps
does not justify uh
yeah it's just it's it's just not worth
it similarly with emails similarly with
what i found as well as random items on
my to-do list whereas i used to think of
my to-do list as i have to get all these
things done now i think of it as as long
as i just get the most important things
done each day it really does not matter
if all the other stuff does not get done
forever like indefinitely it doesn't
matter in the slightest it's actually
all good and unless like a tax bill
comes along which is too easy to put off
or something like that there are very
few things
that are genuinely necessary and
important on the to-do list and they're
certainly not going to be like 10 to 100
of them like i used to have
if i can just do my most important
taskies to each day and maybe and maybe
one or two other things
and i do that every day for a whole year
then i'll make so much more progress
than if i think of my to-do list as a
series of items that need checking off
definitely
i i think there's also a
um
like thinking switch that you make where
you know my to-do list used to be
something that any time i'd strip one
thing off i would immediately think oh
okay what do i want to do next well i
want to start making merch i want to
start a patreon i want to upload a new
video i want to write a script for this
blah blah so there was always things to
add there was a never-ending
incoming stream of things that i could
potentially put on my to-do list and
it's like you said you what you need to
realize is like let me just focus on the
most important things that i want to do
right now once those are done i can
think about adding on a new project it
doesn't all have to get done before i go
to sleep at midnight or whatever
um so
so yeah this this uh thinking shift in
time management from having to get
everything done as quickly as possible
as efficiently as possible
um
to just
taking a little bit less time but
enjoying it exponentially more
is something that's that i've been going
through and that i think is really
important i wish i'd known it earlier i
wish i'd experienced it earlier um
and yeah it's kind of a change that i'm
trying to make now um yeah it reminds me
of something that i heard an emergency
medicine consultant say once on one of
my shifts which is that
don't worry about the list the list is
never ending the patients are going to
keep coming in and there's nothing you
can do about that so just embrace the
fact that there's nothing you can do
about the list and just focus on the
patient in front of you and try and make
that patient have a great time and then
focus on the next one in terms of
priority order in terms of triage and
then the next one and then the next one
and stop worrying about the list it's
all good if we breathe four hours who
cares like you know
we'll be all right we'll be all right we
got this yeah it's that exact point that
there's a never-ending list of patients
and each one of them is going to come
with their sub sub list of tasks that
need to get done yeah um so yeah so
yeah just one at a time in triage
priority order one at a time and one day
trust trust in the process trust me the
ones that don't need to be there we'll
just leave um the drunk people will just
wake up and leave
and as long as you have addressed the
most pressing people as and when and
give them a good experience and everyone
else is doing the same the system will
will
will sort itself out yeah exactly
whereas i find that um
kind of on days this was in my my early
few days when i had like any shifts uh
it would be like oh my god we have all
these eight patients under medicine that
need to be seen as like
i don't need to worry about that that's
way beyond my page you just didn't see
the one
worry about that i'm just gonna see the
one in front of me yeah yeah yeah
would you recommend therapy
because i i tried it for a few weeks i
had a therapist from the school of life
and
after a few weeks i found that i was
really struggling to come up with things
to say
um but it was like a resume and people
are like oh it's better in real life
like yeah what a what was your so i did
it over zoom and there's definitely a
little bit of a disconnect there um
what's your therapist male or female
female okay cool um i just think
well i'll speak for myself but like as a
like man i found it easier to open up to
a woman um because of the biases of like
being a man and holding all your
emotions in and this is not which i
shouldn't be experiencing anyway blah
blah blah
um
anyways so i wouldn't say if that wasn't
working but also a lot of people don't
uh vibe with the first therapist that
they see
it's like super common to change
therapists and like try different ones
until you meet someone who you kind of
connect with
um
and
all this to say like it's genuinely
changed how i think and why i do on a
day-to-day basis i'm a much more relaxed
person than i was before
and it kind of just took someone to like
tap me on the shoulder and be like hey
man like are you thinking about what
you're doing right now like do you feel
okay like how's it going and i hadn't
thought about it i was literally running
on this infinite treadmill
that was never going to run out and i
was just going going going not thinking
about things too much
and um and yeah it kind of
like said tapped me on the shoulder and
gave me a step back
and i guess final question on the
therapy front okay so i'm so i'm sold
i'm gonna give it a go um i do sometimes
think that so a few of my business
coaches end up being therapists because
a lot of their stuff is around like why
are we doing this what are the goals
here like have you really thought about
this but um fair enough what are some uh
as you were going through the therapy
stuff were there any particular
questions that the therapist asked that
made you think oh that's a good question
that you could well that would maybe be
good as like a journaling prompt for
someone who's maybe listening to this
who doesn't want to slash can't afford
to see a therapist i think one of the
things she said to me was um like who
are you doing this for
um and if the answer isn't that you're
doing it for yourself then you know you
might want to rethink about whether you
should be doing in the first place one
of the things that we talked about was
that um
i felt that there were a lot of people
surrounding me in my life that were
going through difficult times um and
they wanted to talk about xyz with me
and um i would never turn away um
someone like that um and so that was
taking like quite a big toll on me uh
both emotionally and mentally and things
like that
um and she was saying to me you know
like
to what to what benefit is this for you
there comes a point where you're giving
away too much of yourself and you're not
you're giving away too much of yourself
and it's only going to be to your
detriment and so
uh she was talking about you know how
maybe you can draw those boundaries or
those lines things like that this might
be a bad example because the conclusion
that i came to in the end was that i
would never say no if it was a close
friend or family because i think even if
i was to make that sacrifice and be
under more emotional stress it's more
important that i try and help the person
who's come to me any final comments on
the therapy side any front um you would
have told yourself earlier or you would
recommend for me the the honest thing i
would say is that i never in a million
years thought that i was someone who
might benefit from therapy or that i
would
need therapy i would find it useful or
anything along those lines and i was
very very shocked just how much i gained
from it and so really what i want to say
is that if you think there's even a
small chance you could benefit from it
or find it useful then give it a go
um
and yeah so you see what happens all
right i'm sold it's gonna happen uh
changing gears a little bit can we talk
about your relationship yes um so how
long have you and alexia been together
so we've been together now for nine
years oh yes
yeah a long long time so you met in
canada or uh we met uh when we were in
high school we went to high school
together oh that's cute yeah um okay so
i have a bunch of questions um sure i'm
curious what it's like
being public somewhat public about your
relationship
and what is like the fact that she is a
youtuber as well and how you balance the
whole like public life versus private
life side of things
um
um i think let's start with the public
versus private life yeah i think
the most important thing that we do that
i do both for myself on my channel and
that we do in videos that we're together
is everything that we show in these
videos is really carefully selected and
what i mean by that is that
i
want exactly zero input from people who
i've never met before on the internet
into what to do in my relationship
a relationship is difficult enough as it
is there's a lot of things to balance
you know and to have other people's
opinions or comment on the smile that
you did at 131 or how you put your arm
on their shoulder at 6 52 is like just
things i don't need in my life right
so a lot of the videos where alexia's
involved are
really travel vlogs um and alexia is in
those in different clips of us just
having fun and going out and drinking
coffee and things like that but we've
been really careful not to sort of sit
down in front of a camera and be like
hey guys this is our life and our
relationship and this is what we like
this is what we don't like because we
don't want to have an online
relationship we don't want it to be in
the public eye
and so that's kind of how we we handle
that we don't really at least i don't
think we put that much of ourselves out
there yeah i've i've had it a few times
with like
generally when filming videos with a
woman so either sheen or elizabeth or
like unjaded jade or doing a podcast
with ruby granger it's like are you
dating yeah it's always it's always the
things of you dating and this like large
amounts of like at 17 minutes and 34
seconds you know that look that came
into his eye it really shows that he's
in love with her or
that smile that she gave him at 19
minutes and 24 seconds really suggests
that she's in love with him or like that
that look he had made it made him look
like it oh god that was so rude that's
like dude exactly like i was i was
looking up
i didn't know what i was doing at the
time but i had like i might notion in
front of me on the ipad to figure out
where the conversation is going next and
it's like when you're doing a live
stream with someone you can't look at
the camera but you want to look at them
and
like all of this stuff and the amount of
like random [ __ ] in the comments of
being sort of people having an opinion
on everything oh my god this video this
this made me realize that ali ali has no
like emotional capacity because he did
not make eye contact with her when she
was sitting next to him he was looking
at the camera instead it's like bro have
you ever tried speeding he's supposed to
look at the camera yeah yeah um yeah so
i guess like how did you decide that how
did do you actively decide that you
wanted to go down the
occasional cameos and travel vlogs root
rather than in the
hey guys let's ask you know answering
dating questions you were yeah dating q
a what he's like as a person kind of
content i think from from the very first
post i ever made online i had a really
conscious decision to separate my
private life and my online life yeah and
i have this huge fear that one day
everyone's going to know everything
about me on the internet
and so i work really hard to try and
separate those two things okay you know
i made a separate instagram page i have
my own private one i made a separate
youtube channel i have my own private
one um and what i post and what i share
online and i talked about this in a
recent video as well is like you know i
only share the things that i want to put
online right i'm i go through the
footage i hold the camera and i film
myself like i decide when i want to film
and what i want to show yeah and it is
all carefully selected because you know
this is an online impression that i'm
giving to other people now it is true
that what i do show on camera is like 99
true to real life but i wouldn't choose
to pick up the camera when i'm really
bothered or upset or angry or something
like that you know i think that makes
logical sense
but i think what people sometimes who
are watching videos don't understand is
that you don't know the person who
you're watching you don't really know
them in a deep capacity more than what
they're choosing to show you online
and so
when someone says you know ali doesn't
have the emotional capacity because he
doesn't look at x y and zed like you're
getting such a small snapshot of this
person in this video that they've chosen
to upload how they act or be off camera
could be completely different you know
and like i don't know i mean we've met a
couple of times hopefully you think that
i'm the same on camera and off camera um
but uh it is really a selective thing
that goes out you know we don't just
show everything do you show everything
about your life no not really right
because you know you want to have your
own private life as well um and so yeah
that's where we were
so from the very beginning with my own
channel i made this huge distinction
between private and public and i think
even more so with the relationship
because there's just this natural
fascination that people have with
relationships and people being couples
online and whatever um i think we've
tried to keep that up of keeping it
offline not offline but keeping it as
private as we can
and how does how do things work with the
fact that alexia has her own youtube
channel as well what do you mean as in
do i i guess
um do you get like so you your your
channel is significantly bigger than
hers so do you get your army of fanboys
and fan girls going over to her channel
and commenting on her videos and wanting
to be wanting to like i don't know be
part of that
yeah how does that work yeah i mean um
i'm so incredibly proud of every video
she puts out because her first like 20
videos are the same as my like i don't
know 50th to 70th video or something
they're so much better than how i
started um and so pretty much every
video she puts out i post it on my
instagram story and i'm like please
everyone go watch it if you're
interested it might be really fun
um yeah no i'm really i'm really proud
of her i think uh i think she makes
really great content and she's a lot she
is the
queen of reflection and introspection
and things like that um and so i think
she does that quite well on camera
something that i'm struggling to do and
i'm i'm working on um
and so yeah i really love her videos and
i promote them as much as i can
um
i'm not quite sure i understand what you
mean by like how does it work
um yeah i guess does she get weird
comments on her videos from like your
fans type thing or um do you get like i
don't know
girls on the internet who are in love
with you who are annoyed that you have a
girlfriend yeah i guess i'm just sort of
thinking about like weird people on the
internet oh yeah i see what you mean
yeah yeah i mean
i get all kinds of weird dm's i'm sure
you get the same like you know there's
the full-on marriage proposals there's
the like the nudes the like you know
people asking you out to coffee and
things like that and i've never gone to
any nudes oh okay yeah
that's just me
and and yeah it's kind of one of those
things that you see and you're like like
why am i seeing this right now you know
i i'm not interested in this there's
like a bedroom this is not why i'm on
instagram exactly like i'm here why are
you sending me this i'm here to respond
to like you cat advice and like studying
motivation um
anyway so see how you know i get all
kinds of weird messages and stuff but
just don't give them attention delete
block whatever the thing is like i'm not
interested in that type of thing at all
right um
you know i'm in this long-term
relationship that i'm really happy in
and i'm i'm you know i'm not going to be
distracted by some stupid dm on
instagram yeah
okay would you ever consider making a
couples channel that's a bit more like q
a about a relationship absolutely no no
no okay again like
you're in a relationship now right
so you know think about how much like
time effort emotion thinking
ups and downs go on in a relationship
yeah and then just add the added
pressure of hundreds or thousands of
people having an opinion on how you guys
interact online or how you appear to be
with each other or
things like that it's just all this
added stress that we really don't need
you know um
so yeah i don't think we would ever go
down that route
um tell me about your relationship
yeah we've not gone public with it just
yet okay um
it feels like a very big move to go
public with it it is yeah and so
given that it's still like early days
it's been like six months um
we've decided that let's let's like
you know
take it slow in terms of like bringing
things into the public domain
one idea that i i really like the idea
of in theory anyway is the idea of for
example having a couple's channel uh
which is why i was asking you about it
because i do follow a bunch of couples
vloggy lifestyle channels
and i i think oh this is really nice
it's really wholesome and it's it's it's
cute how they do cues and ace together
and it's cute how i don't know those
videos of like um a guy asking girls
questions that guys are afraid to ask
girls and vice versa yeah yeah it just
makes me interesting content um
but i guess it does require a large
amount of
uh thinking about
and i guess what you see is definitely
not what is necessarily happening behind
the scenes yeah and what they're doing
is what they're putting out is like a an
airbrushed image of what's actually
going on yeah definitely
um i think another thing to think about
like definitely in my case as
counterintuitive as it might be i
have never been comfortable just pulling
out a camera in group settings with my
friends or you know i mean in the studio
i would never pull out the camera and
start talking uh vlogging because it's
just not something that i'm comfortable
with
and so a lot of my youtube channels me
talking to myself in my bedroom or me
with the camera one-on-one vlogging
walking around or whatever and so being
on camera in front of another person
even my girlfriend is a dynamic that
i don't i don't necessarily want to do
and it's something that i don't think
i'd be very comfortable with okay it's
um
you know
at least for like a couple's channel
type thing i think if you're one off
here and they're doing things together
it's it's whatever um but like in terms
of an official channel i think i would
struggle with it but you know some
people find it really fun and easy so
it's i think it's a personal thing as
well yeah
yeah i think so i think i should i
should treat it with the same
sort of scientific method that you do
for your uh what i enjoy medicine thing
of i have a hypothesis that this will be
fun let's try it out maybe even like
make some videos and not publish them
and see what the vibe is maybe make like
five or ten videos
and if we decide after that point to not
publish them then that's fine they're
interesting memories and if we decide to
publish them great ten weeks ahead in
terms of content yeah
i think like it also depends on how
comfortable you are in the relationship
yeah if you guys both feel very secure
um and you're happy with each other then
those types of online comments are not
going to play as big of a role you're
not going to think about them that much
or
you know i mean you know if you were to
put out a video with your girlfriend
tomorrow that would be a significant
event for the ali abdullah community you
know like this would be actually one out
of ten fireworks like yeah absolutely
exactly through the roof so you're gonna
get a lot of like comments and whatever
a lot of it is probably going to be
really positive um
but um yeah i don't know it's just it's
added pressure it's added pressure and i
think i'm trying to reduce pressure in
my life like i don't i don't want any
more things
yeah up anyway exactly yeah so
yeah i guess it's not something i'm
interested in exploring it yeah okay
nice um
so you've been together for nine years
what's what's the secret to a long
long-term relationship
um
if any i think in one word is
communication for me
like um when we were in
our first degrees i was in toronto and
canada and she was
here in uh bath studying for her
university and i was in canada for mine
and no joke we would have the skype call
open for like 32 hours at a time you
know like 18 hours 24 hours whatever
like the skype call was just a permanent
object on both of our desks it was open
while we slept while we woke up oh we
went to breakfast whatever you know um
and i think that level of communication
that level of feeling together even when
we were apart yeah um is kind of uh what
helped us through then and also just
generally i think
if you don't
well it's hard to give general advice
because everyone's really different but
i'll say for myself like i'm one of
those people who wants to talk to my
partner quite often wants to be involved
wants to be um you know filled in and so
for us
talking and communicating quite often is
helps a lot i think for sure nice
um that's all all very useful i have
more questions to ask you offline
we'll take on uh after this after this
recording
um changing changing directions
finally to the other element of like
other than like relationships and work
that make for a meaningful life
generally health sure you take care of
your health like i've seen some of your
of your vlogs the six-pack abs and all
that like how how do you do it like
what's what's going on there
um
give me advice if you were to be my
health coach what would you suggest for
me sure i eat delivery twice a day and i
don't really exercise so yeah what's
what's going on here the delivery of
twice a day is tough man because
you can't sit here and look me in the
eyes and tell me that the delivery of
food feels and tastes like real food
that you would cook at home
i don't really care i've only only
started cooking home in the last like
two or three weeks
i got like the whole like la crusade
harry potter collection like cast iron
skillet nice nice i made a steak through
three times so far excellent some lamb
chops made something loads of salmon
salmon is so easy yeah yeah salmon is
very easy yeah sure on the big baking
trays as well yeah just throw on tons of
vegetables and potatoes yeah yeah
um
i think
exercise is something that i just
genuinely enjoy fundamentally if i hated
exercise i think this would be a
separate conversation at its core i
enjoy going for a run i enjoy going to
the gym um and i find it very helpful
um kind of tied to the fact that
um i
for a very long time i've been like not
thinking about things not being
introspective and reflective a huge way
for me to sort of offload stress or like
clear my mind and move on to the next
thing was just go for a run go to the
gym not the house healthiest coping
mechanism but it served me for a really
long time yeah um and kind of now it's
just
it's just routine that i need if if i
don't exercise every like two days or so
i'm like i'm itching in my chair you
know i feel like i have to get out of
this room and just
push something pull something like run
um
i i honestly almost feel more like my
body pulls me towards the exercise as
opposed to it's a decision that i make
let me go to the gym right now okay um
but that might also be because it's
become a habit at this point and it's
like just part of normal routine okay
when you're at the gym what do you do
oh i do a lot of stuff um so currently
i'm not in my like
peak physique like gym going four or
five times a week um so what i'm doing
is about three days a week and i
generalize into like a push day which is
uh chest and triceps a pull day which is
back and biceps and then legs and cardio
legs
so i do do legs for everyone for
everyone always commenting on how skinny
my legs are i'm fully aware um
yeah no i i do do legs and i actually
enjoy it now believe it or not it's it's
been a good sort of break from like uh
push and pull days yeah um but it's just
infinitely like harder to train them i'm
a naturally pretty lanky and skinny guy
so um and do you like track macros and
like all that crap no see that's another
one of those things that's just like
added stress that i don't want in my
life okay um i feel like i'm
okay with
eyeballing guessing if i'm like eating
too much or too little but actually to
be honest i don't think about what i eat
too much too little in fact i try and
throw as much food on my plate as i can
because
i find it very difficult to like put on
mass and to grow muscle mass um
and so
yeah i don't really track any of that
stuff no
okay
um so what what would be like your uh
top kind of recommendation for me for
things i should do to my lifestyle to
become a bit more hench um if we ignore
it we take aside the question of why i
want to become hench in the first place
because then that takes it down the
therapy rabbit hole which we can
sure
i think honestly the most important
thing is to just find a form of exercise
that you actually enjoy at the end of
the day if you don't enjoy what you're
doing and you're forcing yourself to go
you're not going to keep it up for a
long time and that makes perfect sense
and so whether you like swimming running
walking gym i don't know
what other activities can you do tennis
exactly exactly yeah whatever the form
of exercise is that you want
just focus on that
um i think doing those types of sports
and activities is different than getting
hench in the gym yeah and you can't just
do those sports and expect to get hence
because it's not going to happen but you
can certainly be like healthy and fit
and active and whatever um the gym is
its own thing the gym is the same thing
yeah i need to figure out a way for
making the gym more fun um gordon is
going to help with that because gordon
needs to be a personality yeah personal
training yeah it's going to happen we're
going to make it fun yeah yeah
definitely um
um and yeah the the eating stuff
um i don't know how do you how do you
find ordering so often
if i order for like two days in a row i
feel like
you know i feel a bit sick
i tend to order like either chipotle
chicken salad or like pokey bowls okay
and so i have like a few healthy healthy
defaults
and i will very rarely order like a kfc
or equivalent you know what's changed my
life
um those like not meal prep companies
but ingredient delivery company
companies like hellofresh and gusto okay
have you heard of them yeah i use
hellofresh for a few weeks and then
stops so very similar to hellofresh we
use a uk-based company i think called
gusto and those boxes have completely
changed their life like we don't shop
anymore at the supermarket we just get
those boxes delivered to the house we
buy the meals that are for four people
and we're only two so we just cook them
and then we have leftover food
for like the next day's lunch or dinner
or whatever yeah and that's completely
changed like how much time it takes for
us to prep to cook yeah because i do
find that shopping for the ingredients
is the hard part it's it's the worst
cooking food it's quite fun shopping is
such an inefficient use of time like i
hate shopping
i despise it same with making breakfast
in the morning i think it's like the the
most inefficient
way to start my day yeah like having
this obstacle of eating breakfast in the
morning bothers me so much and so i'm
thinking of like trying out heal or
something like that to sort of speed up
your process i would recommend um yeah
although i've never gotta go i've now
been on a whole like for the last three
days going into a deep diver on all the
anti-aging longevity stuff okay which is
off which is often in favor
yeah metformin one of the things but
like in favor of calorie restriction
intermittent fasting sure uh eating less
meat
uh not ordering from delivery twice a
day so there's all these things
associated with like longevity that i'm
now
diving into in terms of like what are
the mechanisms behind this and how does
it work and can i make a video about it
and can i apply to my own life yeah so i
feel like next time we meet i will be a
new man
i have been plant-based for the last two
days so that's good all right we'll see
how that goes yeah easy start it's easy
start and uh i'll report that and if you
ever fancy going for a run like hit me
up i think for a road go running pretty
often yeah
no running running is amazing why is it
playing squash do you play squash
uh i don't but i can learn why do you
enjoy running
it's just a repetitive motion right oh
man there's no there's nothing like
running you know you you sweat out like
all your stress
moisturizers
yeah i think like
it's so great because
you're just outdoors like experiencing
you know scenery different shops people
running by the street you know if you go
to the parks you have all that greenery
there as well
i just think it's so great for getting
out of the house and doing something
that's like fun and makes you feel good
yeah what do you listen to while running
if anything only music no new music not
like podcast 3x speed or audiobooks at
2.5 no no i need the high energy like
to keep me going once the music turns
off i like i'll stop you know i can't
keep going it's all about the music yeah
interesting all right i think this is a
good place to end this medic thank you
very much for joining the podcast yeah
my pleasure and uh yeah it's been great
and uh
people can find you on all the links
down below youtube channel podcast all
that shabang i look forward to being a
guest on your podcast at some point yes
absolutely now you're my guest number
10. yeah sick all right so that's it for
this week's episode of deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the itunes store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full hd or
4k on youtube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye